las quemaduras son lesiones de la piel
causadas por el calor sustancias
químicas electricidad o radiación su
médico recomendará un tratamiento basado
en el tamaño de su quemadura y las capas
de piel afectadas por la quemadura la
piel tiene tres capas principales la
epidermis la dermis y la hipodermis o
capa subcutánea que contiene grasa vasos
sanguíneos y nervios debajo de la piel
hay tejidos como músculos facial y
huesos
las quemaduras de primer grado o
superficiales solo afectan la epidermis
el estilo de la quemadura aparece rojo y
seco sin ampollas y se siente un dolor
ligero
las quemaduras de segundo grado o grosor
parcial afectan a la epidermis y partes
de la dermis superior y dermis inferior
el sitio de la quemadura está rojo y
húmedo y es posible que presente
ampollas hinchazón y que se sienta mucho
dolor las quemaduras de tercer grado o
de grosor completo se extienden por toda
la dermis y llegan hasta la hipodermis
el sitio de la quemadura aparece con un
color disparejo que varía de blanco
marrón con una textura seca y curtida ya
que la quemadura es muy profunda causa
poco o ningún dolor las quemaduras de
cuarto grado implican la destrucción de
todas las capas de la piel y en
ocasiones se extienden hasta el músculo
o hueso subyacente estas quemaduras son
marrones secas carbonizadas y casi
siempre indoloras
puede tratar una quemadura de primer
grado remojando en agua fría por unos
cuantos minutos para aliviar y proteger
el tejido aplique una pomada antibiótica
y cubra como una banda limpia y seca
puede tomar acetaminofén o ibuprofeno
para el dolor
trate una quemadura de segundo grado
remojando en agua fría por varios
minutos aplique una pomada antibiótica
para evitar que se infecte y cubra la
con una venda limpia seca y
antiadherente cambio la venda todos los
días y asegúrese de que sus manos estén
limpias el acetaminofeno o el ibuprofeno
pueden ayudar con el dolor y la
hinchazón si tiene una quemadura de
tercer o cuarto grado vaya
inmediatamente a un departamento de
emergencia si es posible eleve la parte
quemada de su cuerpo hasta una posición
más alta que su corazón también deberá
buscar atención médica si su quemadura
tiene más de tres pulgadas de diámetro o
si está ubicada en su rostro manos pies
ingle
nalgas o sobre una articulación
principal